une question qu'a l'air à la fois très
simple et puis très compliqué et donc
c'est pour ça qu'on y réfléchisse
ensemble essayer de voir si on peut
trouver des réponses à cette question
anne-sophie chillar est journaliste et
animatrice de l'atelier de philosophie
de magny les hameaux une fois par mois
une dizaine d'enfants de 7 à 12 ans
philosophe pendant une heure ce qu'on
fait en atelier ces prix sont pratiques
philosophiques c'est à dire c'est pas du
tout une approche par rapport à des
auteurs ou à des textes philosophiques
c'est plutôt manier la pensée et essayer
de décortiquer un peu des questions
philosophiques que les enfants se pose
naturellement de l'arizona ainsi
pourquoi existons à quoi sert l'histoire
qu'est ce qui est juste sont les thèmes
abordés lors de ces ateliers expliqué qu
aux enfants que ces questions là elle
sont universelles que les hommes se les
pose depuis toujours et à n'importe quel
âge de la vie et qu'il n'y a pas de
réponse toute faite qu'il y a des grands
penseurs qui ont déjà réfléchi mais que
chacun à son niveau en fait est amené à
y réfléchir et dans l'intérêt des
ateliers c'est qu'on y réfléchisse en
communauté le sujet de l'atelier de
samedi dernier faut-il aimer tout le
monde mazarine 12 ans a sa petite idée
et messi ont l'après si on veut passer
du temps avec lui et voilà alors que
respecter si on lui dit pas de mal et on
fait pas mal physiquement et moralement
la question du jour est écrite sur un
tableau par anne sophie après quelques
minutes de réflexion les enfants lèvent
la main prennent la parole avec un
dictaphone aux mains et donnent leur
avis sur le sujet
l'intérêt de cet atelier est donc de
réfléchir en communauté et de prendre
confiance en soi le prochain atelier
aura lieu le 23 février sur le thème à
quoi servent les copains